very heavy on the right side. It's very
light on the left side. This is akin to
the row being out of order to the row
not being straight. The rows have to be
straight and the rows have to be as
close to the im as possible. Being on
the right side of the imam is no more
virtuous than being on the left side
unless both sides are equal. If you walk
into the masid and you find that if I
stand on the right or if I stand on the
left I'll be the same distance from the
imam then you choose the right.
any other instance
you stand in the place in the row that
places you closest to the imam. This
affects everyone.
This affects everyone that is in the
prayer with us.
In
Ahmed, the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
led
and he was reciting
and
he
slipped in a verse.
And so after the he turned and he said
because of the mistake that he made in
the recitation
[Silence]
he said I have made this mistake in
recitation
because there are those amongst us who
joined the prayer that had not properly
made their woo and so it affected the
recitation of the imam.
And so if you come to pray with us, make
sure that you perfect
the your will make it properly. Anything
that any one of us does
affects everyone else in the prayer. So
we have an a reward to be had when we
come together for salah. We can't get
this reward anywhere else. It has to be
together in jama.
And when one person makes a mistake in
the row or the row is not balanced or
the woo is not made correctly or etc. It
affects the reward of everyone. Every
single one of us has their reward
docked. We lose parts of our reward
because of these seemingly simple
mistakes.
And so it's very important that when you
come into the masid, you think don't
just pray where the doors are or I
know sometimes we have an anxiety
that maybe I'm going to miss the
even if you miss the it's never a
justification
to improperly make the salah. I mean, if
you if we think about it, we all woke up
at this hour. We made wool. We
inconvenienced ourselves. We came all
the way out here for what? For what
reason? Reward. So then why would we
shoot ourselves in the foot with such a
silly thing? So we want to make sure
that the row is always straight
and that the row is always balanced.
This was so important that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam
refused to start salah until every
single person in the row was exactly
where they were supposed to be. And this
was so important that one of the
miracles
that the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam was given
was that Allah gave him the ability only
in salah
to be able to simultaneously
see the people in the rows behind him
while he's in salah. So Allah gave him
the ability to monitor everyone in the
salah as long as he was in salah. That's
how important it is that the rows be
straight and that the rows be balanced.
They have to be balanced. They have to
be straight. Even if you're going to
miss the rur, if you come in and the
imam is in rur,
if you come in and the imam is in rur,
and if you stand in the wrong place,
you're going to catch the the and if you
go to the right place, you are going to
miss the it is obligatory upon you to
miss the and go to the proper
obligatory. These are not suggestions.
None of these things are suggestions.
These are obligations upon us. And our
children are watching us. It's not okay
for our rose to be out of whack or
imbalanced or we want to get rid of
these old things. We want to make sure
that if the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam himself
walked in through those doors, he would
find us practicing his sunnah and he
wouldn't look down on us as people who
ignored our scholars and ignored our and
and ignored his sunnah saiam
again tomorrow will be a 4:45
the the will be at 4:45 and That's the
only time change for salah starting
tomorrow.
Continuing in
from Alwaj.
Yesterday we discussed what is what woo
is obligatory for or another way of
putting it what is haram for a person to
do who doesn't have
two ways of putting it.
And so who can remember how many things
we mentioned?
Three things. The first thing a person
needs woo to do is what?
Salah. And the second
and the third
Quran. Yes. Touching the musaf, handling
the mus.
Now we will go into a sub chapter of
that or subcategory and that is
what
is preferable.
The times when it is preferable to make
wudoo. the times when it is preferable
to make woo and those are far more
numerous than those things which wuloo
is obligatory for
the first is very general and broad
the remembrance of Allah in general any
remembrance whether it's recitation of
Quran from memory or
the remembrance of Allah subhan allah
alhamdulillah
or even to convey.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
narrated to have
responded to salah
after
he had finished his wudoo. And that's
actually the narration that the author
mentions.
Who here has ever heard of Muajar
Ibut?
Anyone? This is a companion
and this is
part of a group of companions who have
narrated less than three narrations.
There are some narration some companions
who only
narrated one narration
in all of the books of hadith even weak
narrations counting all narrations.
Some who have only mentioned two some
who have only done three. The scholars
of hadith have compiled books
enumerating and listing these companions
who have only one or two narrations.
And these books are referred to as a
category
of books in the science of hadith as
Sahabah.
So
he tells us a story. He says,
[Silence]
for.
So, Muajbud
he says that he passed by the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
whilst he was making
and
mu passed by he saw he's making he said
and most of the time the companions when
they would say to him they would add
and he did not respond.
And so when he finished his wudoo, he
then responded
and he said,
he said,
"The only thing that stopped me from
responding to you in the moment moment
that you said assam to me
when you greeted me is that I disliked
the remembrance of Allah
without being on in a state of purity.
So we have to take this narration in its
proper context. What was the difference
between when he received
a salam and when he answered salam?
Well, he was in the middle of making
mudoo.
So, at most it was how much? Maybe a few
seconds, 20, 30 seconds, maybe a minute
at most tops. Right? and he saw that
Muhaj wasn't leaving.
Now,
if he had saw that he was leaving and he
would leave with the wrong impression or
was not someone who is teachable
or it would make it far too long for the
lesson to sink in, then he would have
responded to
because the others companions tell us
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam used to
remember Allah in all instances and in
all states of being laying down on his
side standing up in
right in all instances he would
remember Allah
without his clothing on with his clothes
with his clothing on etc in all
states of being.
However, what is better? What is better
is that a person have
and so he wanted to teach muhaj here
this. So he went out of his way to do
this in order to articulate to him the
preferable nature of the remembrance of
Allah in a state of
and so this is why he says
now what part of a salam is
the remembrance of Allah.
What part of salam is the remembrance of
Allah?
What is last part? Say what part? What
word? Huh?
For instance,
itself
in
an narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam said
he said
is one of the names of Allah. That's one
of his names.
And so he has placed it on the earth for
you. He has bestowed upon you this name
of his. So spread it amongst yourselves.
So when we say
this is the name of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and this is also what this is also
a dua. It's also a dua that a person
is making and this is why it is not
preferred that people get fancy with a
sal. What do I mean by fancy? Right?
Sometimes it goes into the realm of
mockery which is very dangerous. Right?
Says
it's a joke. This is not how the
companions how the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam gave salam to each other. They
did not give salam to each other as
salamkum.
They did not give salam to each other as
this is how they used to say
to and people they were stepping onto
the battlefield with or
[Silence]
Right? These are things that people say
joking and you know when we grow up in
the west and grow up in this era where
everything is a joke, everything is
funny, nothing is sacred, nothing is off
limits, everything is just geared for us
to have fun, right?
we start to trample on our own sacred
rights, right? Is salam is sacred. It's
not just sacred.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
that it is the envy of the Jews. It is
their envy that the knowledgeable
Jews would envy the Muslim because of
Salam. They wish they had one it,
right? And the strict regulations of
Islam. And if you look into the books of
you'll find that the that the books
and chapters dealing with the rulings of
Salam are very expansive many narrations
at least in the hundreds just about the
rulings of a salam. Who gives salam to
who and how we respond to salam. And if
one person says salam to a group, do
they all have to respond or just one of
them? An elder and a younger, who who
initiates the other with a salam, the
person riding or the person walking? The
person walking or the person seated? Is
salam and shaking hands? Are they
mutually exclusive? These things have
been discussed at nauseium in hundreds
of pages of Islamic literature. Why?
Because of the gravity of this
subhanahu
aldulill